welcome and please be patient while I
begin our live stream for our LinkedIn
audience
and
Welcome to our LinkedIn live audience as
well and my name is Stuart Creek I am a
marketing manager here at simply learn
and I want to welcome you to our event
which is a career Master Class to learn
how to launch a career in automated
software testing
hoping that our guide vendor will be
here he'll introduce himself when he
arrives
meantime
let's get started
we're going to cover automation testing
careers
we'll also be talking about what
this program offers that we uh are
talking about today
how it gets your job ready and
enrollment steps
let's talk about careers in automation
testing
automation testing
is
vital to how software is delivered today
um
we used to live in a world where
software would be refreshed on a
periodic timetable
whole series of
would have those number or at least 57.3
for example
that's given way to continuous
integration in continuous development
um in the
devops
mode of software development
software is continually being
debugged upgraded in the background
and
it has to be tested in the same way you
have to have an automated testing regime
that allows tests to be completed in a
continuous in agile fashion if you don't
you'll never be able to catch up
um
if you consider something like Facebook
where new features are
added tested
deployed
maybe several times a day there's no way
to run a
no way to run a testing regime that's
done on a
uh
timeline of
restrictive
scheduled
test runs got to do it in an automated
fashion
pardon me while I'm getting one of my
colleagues
set here hold on just a moment
and
so automation testing is the only way
that you're going to be able to catch
up with the the ICD cycle
the automated testing
skills open up a career path for you
where you move stepwise upward from
Junior automation engineer at the entry
level
up through different
experience levels each with its own
salary step
you get to
our potential pass or automation
architect automation team lead you move
into the devops
roles of devops engineer devops
architect
become a Consulting automation engineer
and help design
automated testing regimes for other
companies
and
you've seen that the average base salary
in India is eight lock twenty six
thousand nine hundred that's according
to indeed.co.in
currently I'm welcoming my colleague
War who is on mute
I mute yourself in there
good evening
um I'd like you to you could
comment on
the
automation testing
job market and
first on the
necessity of automation testing I
covered that a little bit but you might
be able to add some insights to that
um
So currently
we have launched automation testing with
job guarantee uh program uh just a
couple of months back
there are a huge market demand which we
have uh
got to know about by doing research
there were a lot of feedbacks about uh
having automation testing job guarantee
program for the Learners uh and we came
to know that there is a huge demand with
automation testing uh as a software uh
skills our Learners are also requiring
and uh the companies that are hiring
currently so if you can just look at the
job data for the Indian market to use
demand demanding skill currently in the
market and we are catering to that
demand which uh we are trying to provide
the skill sets for Learners who uh by
which if you
change the knowledge throughout the
program you will be able to get the jobs
as you can see on the screen as a junior
automation engineer a mid-level
automation engineer senior automation
engineer automation architect there are
automation testers and automation
engineering other job roles which you
can apply for and get a job in the
automation testing skills
thank you
so there's a number of different skills
and these are some of them that you need
to have in order to Be an Effective
automation testing professional uh you
need to understand agile management
because devops
really relies on the agile mode of
project management or
deployment management you need to have
skills and Java including the core Java
language JavaScript
code database
you need to have Cloud knowledge General
knowledge about
the web stack
these are all the different elements of
testing
that you'll need to be able to
understand to be effective software
automation Testing Engineer
so I'm going to ask a question of our
audience
and this first question is very before
what has stopped you so far from
becoming an automation testing expert
looking at
getting into this career which is why
you're here today
is it because you haven't found a
program that will help you learn with
the completely comprehensive curriculum
is it because you don't feel that you'd
end up with
practical experience that you could
demonstrate to potential employers
is it because you don't like programs
that just offer you pre-recorded
self-paced field learning
um or is it a scheduling problem
leave the question open firm another few
seconds
I'll share with you the answers
all results
and the more than half the audience
answered that
don't feel that you would end up with
practical experience that you would be
able to demonstrate
uh to employers that you're actually
capable and experienced with the
automated testing regime so let's
discuss how the program that simple
learning is offering automation testing
job guarantee program
the industry aligned so what you're
going to learn is what people in
Industry have told us companies have
come to us knowing our
abilities in technology skills training
said if you can provide people with this
set of skills
we can hire them as automation testing
engineers so we've aligned our
curriculum to that requirement it
includes integrated case studies and
projects Labs that you do in the same
online environment fully digitally
delivered we do it on your
access much of the content on your
mobile device
so it's very flexible in that regard and
you can access it from anywhere
um don't have to go any particular place
to experience the live classes because
they're delivered online as well but
you'll attend weekly live classes with
instructors who will take you through
the material
I guide you through
coding exercises
um you'll be able to interact with them
directly ask your questions
and be able to interact with your peers
in the classes as well so
you've got that type of live
human interaction rather than just on
your own doing self-paced videos
now there are self-paced videos in the
program you can access them anywhere
but from your mobile device from your
laptop
can do that 24 7 so you can fit in that
type of study anytime during the week
that is convenient for you
you need to devote about 10 to 15 hours
a week of effort to this program
that includes the weekend classes and if
you complete the program successfully
all the core material and the final
Capstone project
simply learn guarantees that you will
receive a job offer
within six months of completing the
course
and they will be able to talk a bit more
about that shortly
so again what you get from the program
is your certificate of completion
um
those that you are
a capable
automation testing professional you've
completed the four core courses
the Hands-On projects integrated labs
and you've completed the Capstone
project which takes all those skills and
puts them together into a problem that
is aligned with industry requirements
that you then solve in your own way
under the direction and guidance of
an instructor
and
that becomes part of your portfolio
along with all the other projects you've
done in the course so that you can show
that off to potential employers and
the best part of course program is the
fact that you get a guaranteed job upon
completion meaning that if you comply
with
job guarantee program directions
one of our hiring Partners will offer
you
written job guarantee six months of
completing the course or you'll receive
a refund so
talk more about that I've got vinay here
who is the program manager product
manager for our
job guarantee programs
and you can describe the job guarantee
for detail
um so for everyone's basic understanding
these uh automation testing job
guarantee program it's for the Learners
who are from India only this program is
not available for Learners who are not
resetting in India uh
once you complete the course which is of
uh duration of six months uh your career
services period will start uh from that
period of time till six months so that
is a six months of career career
services period uh in which we will have
helped you to uh
help you for the job search support
there will be some type of services
which will be available for you uh some
of them would be resume preparation help
interview preparation and job board
access to the simply lunch uh simply
lens job board curated by the uh some of
the best Folks at simplina
once you complete your uh you know six
months program and unlock the
certificate and complete all of the
activities which are required as a part
of your curriculum uh we will help you
to find a job and you'll receive a
full-time job offer from any of the
hiring company that we have as a partner
within a six months period of time
uh if you don't uh get a job after
completion of your uh certificate and
the job service period if we are not
able to get your job you will receive a
full refund of your program fees
whatever you have paid for it
um
few of our Learners who have already
been loaded for this program
have passed out and uh or able to get a
good uh jobs in the industry uh one of
our Learners have received a maximum
salary of salary hike of 198 which is a
huge salary rank
average salary hike which we have our
Learners uh has received is 65 per 65
percentage
and uh
not only a Learners have uh were able to
land a good job but uh they were able to
get jobs in different Industries uh more
than five Industries as of now are
Learners were able to get their job into
across it sector bfsi Etc
um
sorry
uh then the question comes who are
eligible for this program what is the
eligibility creditor for the job
currently I'll talk much detailed about
it in the next slide to give you a brief
uh to be eligible for the program uh you
should meet the program
uh you should be able to pass an
entrance assessment test before you
enter into the program uh our team will
provide you a test link uh shown within
a stipulated period of time you have to
uh uh sit for the assessment test once
you come submit this into get enrolled
uh to the program
then for the six months period of time
uh you will get an access to program
complete the program uh whatever the
details are of the program I'll explain
to you in upcoming slides
complete the program in six months
period of time unlock the certificate
and then uh the automation testing
domain
uh when talks about the when we talk
about the detailed eligibility uh credit
and some of the prerequisites uh you
should have minimum 50 academic record
throughout your 10th 12th graduation and
if you have done any pro post graduation
you must have at least 50 percentage as
uh uh academic record throughout your
curriculum
uh you uh must have either a B Tech
mtech BCA MCA BSC in ID or MSC in ID
degree from any accredited Institute uh
you should have at least one of this
degree and uh you should be uh pass out
between 2017 to 2023
if a learner who is not a graduate
between this period of time if a learner
is candidate uh let's say from 2015 or
16 he or she is not eligible to take
this program
uh you should have zero to five years of
Xperia work experience uh to be eligible
to get it enrolled into this program
uh 22 you have zero ideas of experience
you can get enrolled to this program
if you have uh some experience let's say
two years three years four years or five
years you should be able to uh get
enrolled to this program
ideally uh the learner who has three to
five years of experience
uh should have a relevant experience in
a software or IT industry preferably
preferably if you have done any manual
testing kind of a job that would be very
uh ideal for your scenario because you
have worked for three years three to
four years in the manual testing and now
you have to uh upgrade your skills get
it to the automation testing which is a
hot Market currently
uh that would be your ideal scenario but
if you are uh the fresh pass out from
any other degree that I have explained
and you have zero to
one two three years of experience you
should be able to get uh into the
program if you are uh any uh if you have
any work experience uh between 0 to 5
years your current CTC uh should be less
than uh three point lakhs per annum
I should not have more uh CTC than 3.5
likes per annum so that you can get
enrolled into this program uh you see
it's a very uh detailed uh eligibility
criteria we have uh crafted out so that
you have a Clarity and uh we can also
provide you the relevant skill sets
relevant uh curriculum and the knowledge
so that you can uh
uh get enrolled to the program learn and
get a job or your dream job
so I'd like to ask a second poll
question and this relates to the
criteria
uh how much experience do you currently
have
and I'll leave this open for about 20
seconds
close upon about 10 seconds
you're on the streaming services you can
certainly um put an answer into the
comments
and here is the poll result
so
60 of our audience have uh under two
years experience and
you add to that people with uh under
five years experience that's a total of
85 percent of the audience so
uh vast majority of You Are eligible
from The Experience level for this
program
so let's talk about the program itself
and How It prepares you
fortunately my colleague Greg Bender
wasn't able to help us go through the
demo of the learning environment but I
will describe it to you you have
an online environment learning
management system
allows you to manage your curriculum and
your full learning path so it'll show
you all the courses that are in the
program
and it will unlock each one as you
complete the one before it so take the
program in a
particular sequence pass each course
before moving on to the next let's say
you have the right skills available to
you
to succeed in each course building up
the skills step by step you have the
live virtual classrooms as I mentioned
where you meet with your instructors
weekly
you have the ability to see what they're
doing in their whiteboard and their
coding exercises and they can see also
what you're doing when they assign you
an inland in class lab
um you have ability to take your labs
and tests on the same learning
environment so you don't need to go into
any other
space or system
and you do your Capstone project through
the same environment again that's the
last technically a fifth course which
you do Under the direction of a
instructor you meet with them weekly to
go over your progress and your plan for
completing the solution
they can help you with any doubts or
blockers that you've come across during
the week
and guide you to successful completion
and then along the way you get to see
how far you've gone what your progress
is the system will send you reminders if
you're uh behind on any work
um do property to catch up and make sure
that you complete successfully
and uh every step of the way it will
unlock certificates
or the courses that you've done to prove
that you've finished the given course
that you're in and are ready for the
next one so at the final step after the
Capstone project
you unlock the complete program
certificate your evidence that you have
completed the entire program
successfully and your key into the job
guarantee aspect of the the program
um the learning management system
includes support tools that allow you to
ask questions 24 7 from our support
staff allow you to interact a community
chat board with your peers so that you
can compare answers or ask for help from
your peers and also of course to be able
to communicate with your instructors
outside of class hours so that you can
get answers or look at the class files
that they've provided
so all of that is in the learning
management system
and today if you'd like to describe how
the
curriculum is built up
that would be great
Sean Stewart
um so first we have a welcome class for
automation testing
in which our
Learners access managers will take you
through the detailed journey of
automation testing job directly program
which are all the topics we will be
covering uh what will be the time time
table for it what type of Career
Services you will get that overall
orientation or induction session will be
conducted by our Learners access manager
that will be part of our welcome class
uh of the automation testing job
currently program
I apologize for that sorry
uh then uh we will be uh having four
phages
phase one will be Automation and
planning
basically for the Automation and uh
planning and Automation in this this uh
phase will help you to learn agile and
scrum methodologies to deliver projects
on time and learn to create the test
cases uh for the front end
this uh we will cover these in the
planning and automation phase two will
be your functional testing uh this way
this phase will help you to check
whether each application feature works
as per the software requirements using
various Technologies and tools like PDT
s10g junit 5 and 13.
then comes your phase three which is a
non-functional testing this phase will
enable you to create a test plan run and
analyze the test cases which you have
already prepared perform the test
execution and monitor application
performance using the tools
and then comes your last phase which is
cloud automation uh in the cloud
automation phase uh this phase will help
you to in cloud and devops environment
using Jenkins AWS and docker
this is about your four pages I just
quickly
is it phase one will be your planning
and automation phase two will be your
functional testing fix three will be
your non-functional testing and four
phase phase four will be your cloud
followed by which uh you will be getting
access to automation testing Capstone
project
uh in this Capstone project you will be
working on a few Capstone projects uh
industry which will be industry uh
aligned Capstone project you will work
and apply all the skill sets and the
tools you which you have learned in the
face uh one to four you will apply all
the skills and tools in the projects you
will run you will work on the project
and you have to submit the project uh in
the LMS
that project will get evaluated and you
will get the feedback so basically
whatever you have learned throughout the
course you have to apply it uh in the
projects that you you have given to that
is about your whole Learning Journey of
automation testing program
and as I have explained earlier you will
uh come across and use different type of
tools and skills which comprises of
angular Docker for your Cloud
environment uh selenium CSS gate Jenkins
sit press HTML MySQL test NG cucumber
uh and J unit 5 you will come across all
these tools you will get access to the
labs where you can go and practice on
these tools and apply whatever you have
learned in the live classes or the
recorded classes which we have provided
to you
I just want to mention that
at the end of the program when you put
these tools and platforms on your resume
you'll be able to confidently state that
you have used these and have experience
with them you're not just putting them
on your resume to get the
the right set of buzzwords or resume
evaluation but you'll be able to
demonstrate your experience
that's the purpose of the Capstone
project if you'd like to
describe the Capstone project if you
name okay
sure
so as I briefly explained about the
Capstone projects uh what Capstone
project will be doing I'll just quickly
explain in more detailed manner
so basically uh Capstone project will be
your whatever the businesses are
currently doing
uh if a business is running any project
you will get such real life business
scenario you will get a mimic of such a
real life business scenario so that you
can actually apply on the project
whatever it is it will showcase your
expertise in the skills and utilization
of the tools and you can mention it in
your CV and when you are appearing for
the job interview which will give
confidence to the recruiter that this
learner actually has a deep
understanding about automation testing
tools Technologies and the skill set
which is required for the desired job
uh you can choose any of the one project
uh we currently have total four projects
throughout the Capstone project you can
choose any one of them you can work upon
it in detail Manner and you can submit
it in your LMS
uh as I explained to you you will work
on a real world business requirements
what is actually in uh demanding in the
market what you will once you crack the
interview and view now start working in
a company what type of work you will
actually get that is kind of a
simulation we are trying to provide you
in the Capstone project so that you will
get to know and understand what is
actually required what I have learned
and what type of job I'm going to do so
we are trying to prepare you for your
not only for your job Readiness but
after you getting a job that is a very
key uh important thing currently uh all
the recruiters and higher hiring
companies are demanding also
uh these Capstone projects will be very
rigorous uh we will get a very detailed
uh uh project uh project details what
actually what exactly you want to do
you'll be given a case uh where you uh
let's say any Healthcare uh project is
there uh let's say software development
team has prepared one software now you
have to go and uh do the automation
testing in a proper manner whatever the
phases have explained you from planning
to functional testing non-functional
testing and testing it in a cloud
environment Etc all of the skill sets
and tools you have to apply it uh you
know one Capstone project and you have
to submit it it actually uh tests your
skill sets knowledge level which we have
gained throughout the course in a period
of six months
and then once you have done it you have
you gain the confidence not only
confidence you have you can mention it
in your Prof uh resume and during
interview you can tell the recruiter or
a hiring manager that I have worked on
such a uh different type of projects in
during my uh education or the course
that I have completed and I am ready for
uh getting your job and I can actually
do the work that is the confidence level
uh we are trying to give you uh in in
the program
foreign
a success story for example uh this is
on our
website at the
automation testing job guarantee program
page
this is uh SUNY Roy's story
um
where he had reached a kind of uh
Blocker in his career
turned to this course
to help get past that point in his
career um
they all moved up from the position of
an associate to a test lead and works
for the multinational Accenture
um that's an 80 salary hike it's trans
progress from
Associated cognizant to test lead at
Accenture that's a pretty impressive
result
we have
Learners that have been placed into many
excellent organizations
um if you want to comment on
um
the range of companies that work with us
in this program
for automation testing programs we were
able to get a nice job into the
different kind of companies few of the
companies that Stuart has mentioned that
these are the company's essential Camp
Germany cognition PCS Tech Mahindra
Siemens infotech coffee beans exfino and
many more as you can see uh in the
previous slide our learner he has got
placed in the Accenture as a QR test
lead uh one of the inspiring stories of
our current Learners they have got job
into the these type of companies so many
more companies are there you can also
get yourself enrolled in the course
Excel throughout the curriculum work on
your projects and get into the dream
companies like TCS
you can also be the next Sunil Roy uh
once you complete an Excel all the tools
and the skill sets
excellent
so
one more poll question
and it's pretty straightforward are you
interested in enrolling in the
automation testing job guarantee partner
we'll leave this open for about 20
seconds although it doesn't take that
long
just about another five seconds
I'll display the pull result
so more than 90 percent of you in the
audience are interested in enrolling
this would be a great time to tell you
how to do that
enrollment steps are pretty
straightforward
as ziney has described that you contact
us at ask us at simplylearn.net
our learning Consultants will then work
with you to
collect your credentials
for you have the
basic requirements for the eligibility
for the program
and they'll schedule you for the
pre-assessment qualification test
you'll fit for that
again administered online
and based on the result
cleared the test you'll be able to
receive an admission offer
and at that point
accept enrollment
the next
cohort of classes starts on January 7th
with a welcome session on the 9th of
December so
uh if you're intending to do this uh you
have the opportunity to get started
pretty quickly
um it's just over one lock it's one lock
One Thousand and One
um rupee and the
amount can be financed over time as low
as 33.53 a month
which is a zero percent
financing
so to get started
again I'm sorry
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
see if I've got that available
put into the chat box for you
and I'll put that into the chat so you
have that at your fingertips
and
there we go
with that I'd like to go into the
question and answer so you can ask
vanenry your questions
take down the slide momentarily
we'll look at what's come in
from the Q a and chat windows
all right
so
rishikesh
pardon asks
um what's the future for QA testers
what do you see as the the future of the
job marketing
so for QA tester or automation tester uh
we can start with the if you are a
fresher we can start with the automation
tester as a fresher job role and you can
climb up to current managerial level
senior managerial level or Associated
director or higher level position with
your skill sets and as your experience
grows you can expect good opportunities
in different companies and uh getting
jobs across the sectors uh as and when
you try to switch from companies to
companies when you get a good amount of
experience so yes the job market is hot
IIT sector will remain a good uh job
market uh
going a decade at least one or two
decades of Fortuner is uh
that so you can expect a very good
amount of
uh different type of jobs availability
in the market
thank you for that or not uh Merchants
he has uh
two years of intern experience uh
doesn't count that as experience in CV
or does that
does that count as work experience sorry
first one can you please repeat how much
you have experience uh yeah Anand says
he has two years of experience in
internship does that count as experience
in the work
requirements if you have two years of
experience uh you can get enrolled into
enroll into the program whatever
experience you have because uh our
eligibility criteria states that you
have you can have zero to five years of
experience so that is not an issue from
uh eligibility point of view for you
uh